well with the dark energy most people do
think that the universe itself will
exist indefinitely but the the other
question is whether or not there can be
life in the long term future in the
standard explanation for that for the
dark energy Shinsei standard because it
really is a big puzzle but if there's a
vacuum energy that's constant in time it
becomes more and more the driving force
of these of this expansion and causing
ever more acceleration in that picture
then life dies out because you bet you
basically it's cotton perhaps
counterintuitive but as everything gets
farther and farther apart you do have
this floor to the temperature of the
universe set by the vacuum energy it's a
hulking temperature so as you're you're
trying to operate and closer and closer
to this cut off from this vacuum energy
the any kind of life-form actually
overheats so as I said it just kind of a
counterintuitive but you're you just
can't it's something you can't avoid now
on the other hand what we wrote in our
paper is we were saying well but if it's
not a constant vacuum energy if it is
either time changing so that it's
decreasing into the future or that you
have this kind of Cardassian expansion
that I was mentioning in either case
then life could actually continue
because you don't have this floor in the
temperature in fact instead it's also
going down and so you can continue in
clever ways to have life continue to
exist
no and thought at all yeah something
really very unpleasant from our point of
view so I I have no idea but certainly
not people not things will get very very
spread out and distant and cold and I'm
talking about life in the sense of
computation being able to continue well
if you think about our arm our memories
or our thoughts as a type of computation
then is there some way you could have a
molecular cloud just like the kind i was
talking about for the formation of stars
or the different pieces of it
communicate in some way and so you have
intelligence of a completely different
type than than what we're then what we
enjoy so these bodies that we enjoy are
not going to make it